since I started working there in 2014
it's only improved as the years have
gone by we had 56 percent female mixed
non-binary in 22 we achieved 51 female
mixed non-binary in 21 we had mixed male
female Headliners in both those years
and we have a track record of giving new
kind of giving artists their first ever
Festival headline performance I think in
the last as of 2021 in the last six
years 50 of our Headliners it was their
first ever Festival headline show
thank you
is there fear
in across festivals in general and to
broaden it out from just picking on you
and I apologize for that is there a fear
that more female artists would lead to a
loss in revenue or is it the challenge
that you don't have the artist signed
you don't have the pipeline you have the
album Cycles Etc all sort of comes
together and it's not about Revenue it's
about being able to find those artists
in the first place
I think at the top on the headliners it
is about it is about all the things that
I just discussed
um on the lineup further down the bill
there's a lot less excuses there's so
much incredible female Talent out there
that you would have to not be doing your
job to find them
um but in terms of an act that can hold
a crowd for thirteen and a half thousand
people
that takes time to come through and that
takes money and effort and attention
across all areas of the industry
thank you do you think there should be
any responsibility on festivals to make
sure their lineups are balanced
absolutely and how much of that is
incumbent on the bigger festivals
um I am not sure I can particularly
comment on that
um because I'm just here representing
under the road and The Association of
Independent festivals you feel that the
Association of Independent festivals is
making a real effort yes
is that matched
other
organizations
well I mean the stats would say no
thank you and I'm sorry all of my
questions are directed to you and I
apologize we will bring in the other
Witnesses fret not
um I just want to understand
whether exclusivity agreements
uh that might exist for some artists
make it harder to have balanced lineups
yes because if we talk about the
talent pool at the top that is capable
of headlining a massive show
um and it's not in any particular year
it could vary there could be lots of
people on an album cycle and the pool is
very rich but
um it definitely diminishes the chances
of of artists being able to headline
multiple events so those with bigger
budgets and more money
have first dibs I suppose
and do you think that there should be
any um responsibility
cells all organizers or both to say no
to exclusivity agreements or are they
just a fact of life that that need to be
accepted
I think
within the industry there seems to be an
acceptance that exclusivity on
headliners
is something that we all understand
um but lower down the bill is where it
gets more complicated
um
exclusivity on Headliners is problematic
for us largely because it comes from
major festivals as opposed to other
independents
but your headliner is your Headliners a
lot of the time they're selling your
tickets so you need to kind of own that
uniqueness
but luckily I mean under the road has
always sold to its whole lineup we
normally sell a third of tickets before
we even announce and we have a very
loyal audience they're like coming to us
just because they like the festival
thank you can I just bring Kate in on
Headliners in particular yeah and you've
just actually answered part of what I
was going to ask you there I wondered
whether you monitored gender or sex of
the people that come to your festivals
that buy the tickets and how much if any
impact not having a woman as a headliner
might have on that you know are you
aware of that I know you said that
people come in buy tickets for the whole
lineup
um
but I would I
I would imagine that there's a certain
there's obviously a certain draw for the
headline Acts
more so
um I don't have those stats to hand but
I'm happy to provide them after the fact
in writing do you do you actually
capture those yes those figures okay
thank you
Anna
thank you so much chair and thank you
for for joining us today my questions it
really relate to Primavera so they're
going to be directed to Marta but feel
free to jump in if you want to add
anything hey Jordan Lauren so um
I have to be honest I am I'm not really
a music goer however and I do know the
hard work that you and the team have
been doing and I'm really wanting to
pick at it a little bit more and gain
more of an understanding of how this
came about and but then also what have
been your challenges in achieving that
50 50 lineup
first of all thanks so much for for
having me for having us here because
it's such an honor to belong to a
festival which is not from the UK and
being able to be here and explain how
we've been doing this in a journey that
started in 2018
in 2018 almost without noticing we
achieved around 30 percent of female
representation in Primavera sound and we
just noticed when the festival was over
and then we thought okay if we achieve
this 30 33 percent of female
representation without even noticing
what if we tried what if we really tried
to do it and next year 2019 uh we
achieved what we called back then the
new normal which was it should be
absolutely normal to have 50 of women or
non-binary Acts or whatever that doesn't
mean to have only white men with guitars
on stage
so
that year the the challenges were
just being in that mindset somehow and
trying to fill in all the all the slots
as Lauren was saying
um Headliners might be more difficult
some years depending on the routes that
they might have if they have released a
record or not but we've always believed
that somehow Headliners are also what
you call a headliner it's not like a
computer that you just bought and it
comes with X gigabytes of memory
she is a headliner if you put her on
that slot it's a very usual example that
I always talk about so lunch she had
been to the festival before
and she was occupying lower spaces on on
the poster and then we thought she
should be a headliner why not we've seen
her career growing we think that our our
audience
might enjoy this and we are pretty much
sure that she deserves to be on on this
lot or Rosalia who's coming back this
year after playing several times in
Primavera and the last time she was
already a headliner so the the
challenges are
for us basically right now that we are
competing against ourselves
because we are here because we put a
spotlight on us
so now we know that we have to live up
to the memory which is not a memory it's
in I think so however you overcome those
challenges
because it sounds like within the the
team at Primavera that there seems to be
a cultural attitude where why isn't this
the new normal in my account we have 50
like 50 50 lineups so moving forward how
do you think you're going to overcome
those barriers
I think that an important clue is also
to have a very diverse team
it's uh it's really important that in
our company in any company we are also
50 50 men and female that we have
several heads of of the apartment uh we
have a radio station she is a director
the coordinator of the booking
department she is also a woman in
logistics we have a woman in charge of
press and uh MPR
me so I think that first of all it's
very important that you look inwards and
you and then you might think okay are we
doing what we can really do in our
company because if all the company is
only white people which in our case
that's something that we really need to
to improve because we don't have enough
uh racial diverse stuff yet
um do we have enough uh people from the
lgbtq
community do we have enough women do we
have enough non-binary people and then
it is easier to think different
and then also that means that our
audience is going to be different they
are going to ask different things from
us and then we will be able to deliver
but it's not something that comes just
from one day to to another the
challenges keep keep changing yeah every
part of the poem music to my ears
um I thought that was quite funny as
well and so I'm curious to learn a
little bit more about what feedback
you've gained from from the general
public from artists and Bookers from
having this 50 50 lineup
I won't lie 2019 was hell on Earth at
the beginning
when we released the lineup we had a
tremendous backlash especially online
which of course it's very easy and cheap
to do we feel that many many people that
felt Primavera sound as something of
Their Own
felt betrayed this is not appealing to
me anymore this is not the the festival
that I used to attend and then we
started receiving all this backlash
saying uh this is only a PR stand you're
not a music fan your music festival you
are not a women's Community why are you
doing this we only care about music
um and we received a lot of criticism
online
uh just after this first wave we started
receiving
praise and more praise and more praise
especially from people that had never
attended a music festival before because
they didn't feel safe
because the music that was displayed in
music festivals was in the music that
they were listening to in their bedrooms
maybe because
um they they thought yeah I'm not
interested in this so then we started
receiving a lot of comments um from very
young gay boys that said yes I'm gonna
come because my friends are also coming
and I think that I will feel safe in
this festival and I think that's
something that is going to be also
talked about in this community about
safety in uh in our festivals we started
receiving praise about okay I really
love this band and it's really small but
now I feel that you have programmed
these girls that are doing music the way
I would like to do music as well if if I
can do it at some point
and then
um
also answering a question that she she
asked first the proof that this works is
that for the first time
um in one year that we had more audience
than ever we usually sold out but that
year we have increased our capacity so
on that Thursday we had about I don't
know 60 000 people more or less Friday
as well on Saturday we sold out with 65
000 people
with the lineup that portrayed a
classical let's say Indie act with a
white guy James Blake
the biggest Latino Superstar from
reggaeton Colombia J Balvin
and a girl from Barcelona Rosalia that's
diversity and we sold out the festival
with increased capacity for the first
time ever so it works so if you want to
look at it financially it works you know
senior reduction in tickets
capacity that's really interesting you
you said something there that I want to
pick up on so that young gay boys have
anecdotally said that they feel safe
there do you think because we've in
committee have heard evidence from women
in different parts of the music industry
who have very often spoke about their
experiences that they don't feel safe
more often than not do you think having
not just a 50 50 lineup but having a
gender balanced Workforce has created a
safe space Atlas concert
absolutely because then you think
differently because if you only have men
on your stuff they typically don't feel
unsafe unless they are
um
um from lgbtq communities if you only
have straight guys in your company it's
difficult that they have felt threatened
but if you have a lot of women in your
company if you have people from diverse
um social uh backgrounds
it's probable that you have felt unsafe
that you have felt scared going back
home that you were lost between stages
and you didn't find your friends so then
when you're able to work on this other
side of the business you think about
that and if you try to create the
festival that you would like to attend
as a as an audience you have those
things in mind
absolutely for sure in a lot of these
three major festivals will sell out well
in advance
um of the lineup actually being
announced so do you think this has
created a sense of complacency amongst
um organizations when they're having a
gender balance or potentially looking at
having a gender balance lineup
could be absolutely the problem is that
uh as we say in Spain is
which means I'm gonna have bread today
but I'm gonna be hungry tomorrow
if we don't change the ways that we use
to do things at some point our audiences
are gonna be are going to stay at home
we grow old we have kids we don't have
the energy anymore if we would just try
to cater to the audience that used to
buy the tickets at some point they
wouldn't be there anymore and by the
time that we try to change the lineups
to appeal to someone different
you will be so far away the train has
passed so if we still working we still
work the way that we used to
um those sold outs won't be there
anymore yes you've kind of just answered
my last question there but I'm going to
ask it and just put a more in a more
specific manner in
F having a gender balanced lineup
doesn't increase
tickets but if that's not a factor why
should organizations and other festivals
have gender balance lineups what what
positives have you seen from that since
why should any company have gender
balance stuff
just yesterday the Spanish government
passed a law that forces companies in
evex 35 those are the the companies in
um in uh in public offer also
governments also uh electoral
candidacies
and any kind of public organism to have
at least 40 percent of women on their
stuffs that was a law that was passed
just yesterday I still wonder why this
doesn't apply to many other things I
understand that this can't be directed
to smaller companies but for example I
think that um that yeah
handling holding um big companies
accountable matters and then if that
happens with uh finances and you know
this kind of um of businesses why not
um why not festivals we we should do it
because we just have to if we want to be
um the mirror of of our society I think
so Marsha thank you so much I didn't say
at the start that I'm not really a
festival goer but I think you've
convinced me otherwise thank you my
mission here is done
Marta can I just ask the same question
that I think Kate asked Lauren about
when it comes to to ticket sales do you
know what your audience gender breakdown
is and and would you know that on
Advanced ticket sales so before people
even know the lineup do you know whether
it's 50 50 or we are actually in a 50 50
I think that last year it was even a
little bit higher on female attendance
thank you and this might be commercially
sensitive you don't have to volunteer
this information but what percentage of
your sales happen before you've released
your lineup
it uh depends a lot last year it was
crazy because of course Primavera didn't
happen for two militias 2020 in 2021 so
what we did was a double Edition for two
weekends and we sold out for a festival
or a double Edition that was 10 days
long so it really depends a lot this
year we have two editions in Spain one
in Barcelona which is actually going to
happen next week and another one in
Madrid the week after so this year is a
little bit different uh let's say I
don't know maybe I'm just from the top
of my head maybe 35 to 40 percent uh
this year was uh before announcing the
the lineup last year uh it was
absolutely everything before announcing
and it was a double Edition
thank you and can I particularly thank
you for coming over when it's the
festival next week Kim actually and to
be to really clear
um on maternity leave so okay so that's
why my colleagues are not missing me and
I'm I'm happy to to be here thank you
Kim thank you Chad and good afternoon
panel I'm just want to pick up on the
issues about women's safety at live
music and my questions are directed at
John the musicians you and you and John
describe sexual harassment live music
events has been shockingly normalized
and seen as an occupational hazard so
what do you think are the major barriers
to reporting sexual harassment and
assault at Musa festivals and what
should be done to challenge it thank you
thank you for that question
um we ran a survey in 2019 to our
members looking specifically our people
who experience sexual harassment and we
had over 800 responses to that survey
um almost half of the members who
responded to experience sexual
harassment and over 60 percent witness
someone experience sexual harassment to
your point
um 40 over 85 percent of the people
who's experiencing sexual harassment
didn't report it and the biggest barrier
was fear of losing work or workplace
culture with Sciences as a barrier and
the fear of using losing weight is a
unique aspect that I think makes sexual
harassment more likely and unreported in
the music industry so our members all
work in a range of venues pubs Festival
sites where alcohol and drug consumption
is more likely there's really informal
work and practices employment relies on
Networks
so you can see under these and kind of
um ways of working absorb it creates a
culture where sexual harassment is more
likely to happen and more likely to go
under report it as well
um so they're the main reasons that
members don't report it for fear of
losing weight and that workplace culture
what we'd like to see happen the MU
wouldn't fully supports we're fully
support of the Wake protection belt
especially the third party harassment
protections as well I think it was um
I've got to start somewhere here it was
60 47 of members have been sexually
harassed by an audience member so those
third-party protection is a really
important part of that legislation to
our members so we're in full support of
that and we think that's an important
step in creating safe workplaces for our
members
um if we just go back and tackling and
preventing sexual harassment so we have
a service called safe space which is
open to the Italian music industry and
that is set up specifically where anyone
can report instances of sexual
harassment or abuse in the music
industry and through that we're able to
provide legal advice and support where
appropriate or signpost to support
services we can't support
um
information readily available and easily
available to everybody safe space yeah
it is and we work with venues and
festivals to make sure that that um
those posters open dressing rooms or
rehearsal spaces to make sure that that
service is known but I will say there's
massive gaps there where where women
just don't know that service exist or
don't feel that they can access it for
numerous reasons this is why we're also
supportive of the creative independent
standards Authority we think that's a
necessary stacked up or plug that gaps
and help change the culture of the music
industry or support the industry to
change culture
um we'd like to see more of the way to
provide visible report and mechanisms
our festivals and live music venues and
train them for security and people
working at the venues as well so they've
got more of a education and how to
respond to reports of sexual harassment
and Seymour festivals engage with the
initiatives like aaf safer spaces what I
know Lauren will be able to tell you
more about and that provides physical
safe spaces and events and festivals and
that's specialized support for Google
who experience those behaviors there as
well you just mentioned about providing
more training for security staff yeah
what um how does that take place and
who's responsible for delivering that
because that is often one of them the
major barriers isn't it you know in
terms of
um security staff maybe not acting
um responsibly enough and um
um and speedily enough you know in terms
of challenging these incidents
definitely it's a massive Gap and we've
worked out with good night I hope to I'm
sure you've all heard of good night's
old campaign and they will provide
training like that there's really a
strain of providers if I'm honest I
could provide wider equality diverse
inclusion training but specifically on
how to respond to instances of sexual
harassment I think that's a crucial part
as well so and the report mechanism to
go along with us it was something is
reported it's logged and we can start to
build a picture of is this venue
specifically a problem where we have
sexual harassment commonly how do we
address that that's an important part of
the puzzle of fixing this culture as
well and it's that one the problem but
also John in terms of the reporting
mechanisms you know in terms of artists
and women attending live music events
knowing what and where they can go to do
that absolutely and it's complicated
fear without most of the people who are
working in the industry are Freelancers
well again so they won't necessarily be
a HR department or a report mechanism in
place in a lot of places but where they
are in in place we do see reports
obviously but again there's still those
barriers of worrying about what's the
consequences for important
um that's why I think an anonymous
report mechanism is really important as
well
and some artists you know performing at
Live Events won't have access to
appropriate facilities you know and I
don't know whether you see that also as
a barrier in terms of getting more women
involved in these events definitely it's
when we've had a Workforce that's been
historically dominated by men then women
are often after photo we've had reports
where women are there's no change in
facilities for women are venues so women
will be getting changed in cars and
which obviously raises safety concerns
or to be asked to share a dressing room
with the rest of the band members and
things like that and so there's multiple
issues going on there where it creates
quite an unwelcome environment for women
you mentioned um sorry your union has 30
000 members what was the breakdown in
terms of gender in terms of
approaching 40 women of membership yeah
and we do a lot of ways to ensure that
we recruit more women that we've got
Services specifically for women like
safe space or the maternity services
that we provide
um and also we may do a lot of work to
make sure our committees are 50 50
splits as well
John my next question so for Marta and
Lauren and it's very much about what men
are doing what you're doing with men to
call out and
um challenge these behaviors at live
festivals because until men stand up and
challenge then a lot of these incidents
continue don't they
Lauren
um well part of the um safer spaces
Charter which was originally launched in
2017 and relaunched in 2022
um part of it is to raise greater
awareness about sexual violence at
festivals
um part of it was to take a survival-led
approach to tackling sexual violence and
a lot of it was to spread
um information about being inactive
bystander and about consent
and so there are the kind of the five
D's of being an active bystander which
we train all our heads of department and
they in turn train our stewards and bar
staff on and that's a really really
important place I think to start with
with the men that we work with that
attend the event as staff or artists or
students or anyone
and that's a resource that's easily
available online it was devised by right
to be
so that's like probably one of the the
most important ways and I think a lot of
it probably comes back to
I suppose everything that kind of Marta
was saying in terms of representation
it's about ensuring that your Workforce
is diverse and so you have the opinions
of people from multiple different
backgrounds feeding into the situations
and feeding into what is the right or
wrong way to do things
before that your survey identified the
issue has been normalized and just an
occupational hazard so it's about
providing information isn't it to all of
the people involved in the festivals to
ensure that they know that this is a
serious incident that needs to be
reporting same over two martyr in terms
of what you do in terms of your
respective festivals in terms of you
know asking men to call out sexual
violence
started in 2018 with a protocol that was
developed by the Barcelona town hall and
it was protocol against sexual
harassment in Nightlife venues and
festivals we were the first ones to
implement that that protocol together
with several venues and the Barcelona
town hall and in 2019
together with this campaign of The New
Normal we kind of spread the scope and
we made a new protocol by ourselves
which it was called nobody is normal
because what is to be normal nowadays so
it's not only against sexual harassment
but also a celebration of diversity it's
a protocol against fear
a festival is a space for transgression
uh for Community for celebration and no
one should be afraid of expressing uh
her own his own or them themselves in in
a music festival so just a couple of
days ago we announced again the the
protocol that um uh has different
aspects for example the the safe spaces
in the festival where you can just go
and stay for a while or you can go and
Report anything that might have happened
to you or that you might have witnessed
we have uh some stuff that's working
around the the venue and I I want to
stress how important it is in line of
what John was saying that this has to be
um
felt as something that is not not
threatening so this stuff is composed by
so many diverse people in terms of race
uh of physicalities of sexual
orientation so me as a woman or a guy or
whoever is feeling unsafe can feel that
these people will listen to to them
and also our staff is strained as well
in order to detect any possible uh
conflicts I think however that
everything is linked so the more we
invest in a gender balance lineups more
diverse our audience is going to be and
then the safer it's going to be for for
everyone let's let's say that
um an anti-sexual harassment protocol
the goal is for it to disappear
so we don't have to use it anymore thank
you master thank you panel there are my
questions thank you John can I just go
back uh to what you were saying uh
specifically about venues so if the
Musicians Union kind of gets wind that
there's a particular venue where people
are unsafe where there are more reports
of sexual harassment abuse assaults
what do you actually do how do you as a
union go about tackling that with the
venue okay so it feels important just to
say that the the safe space service
where people report that through that
survival-led so we'll always be led by
to Survivor if they want to take action
or not but to your point if we got
multiple reports about a venue and we're
able to contact our venue without
revealing anyone's identity we can have
a conversation with that venue to say
that we've received multiple reports of
sexual harassment in this instance in
your Venue is there something specific
about the way your Venue set up is it
the policies and procedures that aren't
in place that are enabling this to
happen what is the culture of your Venue
that's enabling so many incidents of
sexual harassment to happen and we're
with them to recommend policy train and
there's actually a sample policies on
our website so it's quite easy and
accessible for them to access and
Implement themselves I do understand
though and I must say in the Grassroots
sector there's a funding issue there
where many of the vendor venues won't
have the money for funding so we've done
schemes um in Liverpool not just because
I'm from there but in Liverpool where
we've worked with a number of venues
where we funded part of the training as
well so they can access that because it
was out of their reach so it's working
with the the musician communities as a
whole including venues to look up how we
can tackle this together what the
support is there from us and and venues
are receptive to those conversations are
that they want to improve absolutely
yeah yeah venues contact us about this
and proactively in a lot of cases not
just on sexual harassment but we're
talking about diverse lineups as well
how do we diversify the the acts that we
book obviously that ecosystem leads
right up to Festival stages so it's an
important part of the conversation so
venues are actively looking to make
change and as I said the barriers there
to do with funding or staff some menus
have run by two people so obviously
that's going to be really difficult to
manage but the willingness is there it
just needs a bit more support thank you
Kate thanks chair my question is for
Lauren please um can you tell us about
the monitoring that you do of festivals
that have signed up to the aif's Charter
of best practice please
um yes so
um over 100 festivals have signed up to
the Charter
um the priority monitoring is making
sure that they have published their so
the charter encourages everybody to
follow the best practice and adapt it
for their own event because everybody is
different so everybody will take the
principles and Implement them in a way
that is suitable for their event and the
charter requires that you publish that
and you make that fully accessible
online
um and then there's kind of a check-in
every year post season to see how the
procedures have gone see what may have
worked what didn't
um kind of
um sharing knowledge about what one
event might have done that was really
successful or what might not have gone
quite so well you know kind of
anecdotally a lot of people had success
with the ask Angela campaign using that
on their bars a lot of people introduced
new welfare spaces where they didn't
have them before kind of specific safe
spaces they didn't have before
professionals that are trained kind of
in mental health and in dealing with
those that have been through sexual
harassment or abuse on site or in the
wider world
so that's that's kind of the the
processes I suppose but it's down to
each and every individual to implement
what they think is correct for their
event and everybody who signed up to it
really really cares and really cares
about learning from each other that's
one of the really important things that
aif provides is a network so we can all
improve together
yeah so that they sign up and share best
practice Etc but do you check that in
any way that staff have undergone
training so that they know what to do if
they observe or hear a
sexual violence
um well that aif is a not-for-profit and
I think there's only two employees so
it's beyond their scope to be kind of on
the ground physically checking that that
everything happens in the way that the
festival is saying it should that has to
sit on the individual organizer
okay and that leads nicely into my next
question we asked safe gigs for women if
festivals were supporting them
financially
they said no just by often being asked
to attend so
in your view why are festivals not
financing them
um well I I don't actually have an
answer to that safe gigs for women they
work directly with aif
um the the the safer spaces Charter and
policy was developed with safeguigs for
women
along with un women Rape Crisis England
good night out and girls against
so there is communication directly with
the people that are experienced and know
what they're talking about
but when we talk about financial
investment into the safety of our
audience this doesn't just come from
working with with outside organizations
it's an internal procedure
you know we
um end of the road when we signed the
charter we took this Charter as a
starting point and we then went away and
we worked with un women not safe gigs
for women a different organization and
we put money into that and they helped
us develop our procedures and our
policies
we invested in the time to train all the
heads of Department in our procedures
and policies and invested in the time
for them to then train their departments
on site
um you know and there's very very basic
things about safety that you invest in
you invest in good lighting you get
invest in good risk assessment it's kind
of comparable to what John was saying
you know in terms of venues when you
notice that there might be repeat venues
that are problematic you have to ask
yourself okay why is that happening on
that particular spot part of site is
there an alley with toilets that's
poorly lit like what do we need to do
about that and it's when it's working
with security companies and making sure
that you're spending your money on
security with the best possible company
out there and I know it's been spoken
about in this committee before but there
is a serious skill shortage
um with security companies
um so the kind of the investment in the
ecosystem of making safe safer spaces at
festivals comes from all different
directions it comes from investing in a
diverse Workforce and everything Marta
was talking about yeah
okay so kind of specifically around
volunteer groups should funding be a
condition of festivals being a signatory
to the Charter do you think
funding volunteer groups yeah should
funding of the volunteer groups be a
condition of festivals being a signatory
to the AIS Charter now I think the
government at wide should be funding
these organizations
um not-for-profit organizations have the
expertise they don't necessarily have
the same red tape and they already know
what they're doing they lack the
resources
um I I would love to see it come from
within and I am open to those
conversations no one has brought those
conversations to me
um but I do think that the independent
sector is woefully underfunded
um
yeah okay
can I just ask a question Lauren when
and I think you use the phrase make sure
that you're working with the best
security companies how do you go about
determining that what are the the
measures that you use both in terms of
accreditation but also in terms of
sharing experiences with other festivals
who were good and who were bad
well you've hit the nail on the head and
the kind of the last point you you share
information with other festivals about
who's done a good job
um you do your due diligence on the
company take professional
recommendations you take personal
recommendations and you make sure that
they all have the correct training in
place but I do think that the training
that security go through you know you
have to go through Sia training to get
your badge I think that there are
massive holes in that training
um I think a lot of the issues with
security could be solved by plugging the
holes in those training bringing in
these organizations that we've spoken
about like
girls against good night out safe gigs
for women to inform a more detailed and
survivor-led orientated package as part
of that license because if we knew the
professionals that turn up on site who
are supposed to have already gone
through this training we retrain them
how we like to do things but if we knew
that they were already arriving with
like a higher standard of
professionalism in this area it would be
a massive massive relief
you use the phrase holes in their
training the gaps
um I'm not necessarily going to ask you
to list what those gaps are here and now
but I think it would be useful for us to
you know just have an idea of the
examples of that because that could very
well be an area in which we wanted to
make recommendations as to how for
accreditation for licensing that
training needs to be improved
I can certainly provide some answers in
writing afterwards but for now I can
certainly say that it's very outdated
and it's definitely not
um survivor-led
um and it's definitely coming from a
world that is very male dominated the
security industry is incredibly male
dominated and Incredibly White
thank you for that Caroline
thank you good afternoon everybody
lovely to see you all and I'm going to
focus on you John I apologize uh I want
to talk to you about the music industry
more generally so you'll be aware that
uh a few years ago in response to some
of the concerns around
um misogyny and uh sexual harassment and
bullying and what have you within the
sector The Musicians Union alongside the
independent Society for musicians set up
a a code of practice
so we took evidence the other day from
the chief executive of the ism who told
us that this code of practice that they
developed in partnership with you had
been and I'm going to quote this a
resounding failure because the industry
and I'm going to quote it again doesn't
take much notice of codes what are your
thoughts on that you know what I
wouldn't I wouldn't disagree we've had
over 50 signatories ago the problem for
me is not the code the problem is is
what K pointed out before the code isn't
monitored the code isn't enforced in any
way basically we got the resources to be
able to do it so we do get signatories
to the the code of practice which
outlands acceptable behavior and
standards that we expect to see in the
music industry what we've got with the
code is something to hold people
accountable to so organizations so where
we do receive reports as they spoke
about earlier we can then contact them
and provide recommendations for training
and policy or if necessary take them off
the list of signatories in terms of the
impact that has in the industry I can't
imagine that very severe or or people
will take that much notice of being
removed from a signatory what we are
working on at the moment is a revised
code of practice with the BPI the eye of
his Academy and UK music which will be
much more overarching be supported by
training and be much more robust code
and there's also the anti-racism code of
conduct the association from black labs
and music I know Charice was on on the
first session that is going to be much
more robust that will be monitored by
black lives and music and again
supported by training so yeah whilst
they don't disagree I don't think it was
a complete waste of time but I don't
think it had the impact that we would
have hoped and this sort of
pair of
him forth to how it can be sort of
um what the kind of checks and balances
can be that you know used against those
that aren't enforcing the code to what
extent I mean you know we're talking
about a a
multi-multi-million pound industry in
you know at its highest levels uh so one
would have hoped that the industry could
find a way to
find to um to to come together and put
in place the systems and processes to be
able to enforce that quite robustly you
know and amongst itself because it's
good for the industry right particularly
given that it's
um that so many of your consumers are so
young and impressionable so to what
extent
do you think it's it's to the
music industry yourselves and and and
others to to put in place this um these
systems and to what extent do you think
the government's got a role to get
involved yeah I think
um as you pointed out both have got a
role and as you know that um most of the
industry certainly the people who are
working with like a BPI are UK music and
I've been involved from the beginning in
the creative Independence stanza's
Authority and will be supporting that so
we've supported it from the creation and
will supported it when it launches as
well again because of the issues you
pointed out it's a multi-million pound
industry the issue I think that we have
is it
um does lots of different sectors of the
industry and lots of different ways of
working staff by Freelancers and each
they won't necessarily be that different
but there'll be nuances within each
sector so we're looking for sectorial
expertise from the education sector the
classical with the live industry
Festival so we can really address those
problems properly and that's where they
think it's the music industry's
responsibility being part of that group
that's helping to launch the creative
independent standards Authority where
the government has got a role to players
in legislation so as I pointed out
before the the working protection Bill
we're really interested to see that pass
with the worker protection bill I think
that's passing through the house of
parliament currently and I think there's
been some issues with it around the
third party protection harassment we're
really Keen to see that pass for the for
the reasons before
um the other issue that we have with our
members is that some of the way as it's
pointed out before 90 of our members
work in the freelance capacity and
because of the way that they work some
of them fall through the gaps in
legislation of the protections might be
a quality act for um affords so when
they come to us for legal advice on
discrimination or sexual harassment we
find ourselves in a position where
there's no legal route to Justice we've
got a campaign about it called protect
Freelancers too that I would recommend
that you take a look at if you haven't
seen it already so they're some of the
ways I think the government can help
obviously there's wider issues when we
look at representation of women in the
music industry so not just the safety
and that feeds into the conversation
that we're having earlier about why
didn't we see more women in headlines
Lots
um am I jumping ahead with my questions
now on
um
so I mean the the I work with a lot of
women members obviously I'm my job and
safety is one of the major concerns that
they come to us with the second concern
and a barrier what we see about
representation of women in the music
industry is child care and the way that
works for Freelancers so
um it's especially difficult when women
go on tour as well so Freelancers where
you can schedule a freelance of
musician's work and schedule can change
day by day and the location can change
quite often so it leaves parents with
child care
um when they've booked child care it can
often leave them which I'll give that
they don't need and then they've got to
Scrabble around to rearrange the child
care again and the last minute nature of
freelance bookings means that women with
care and responsibilities have got to
work out these super complex Child Care
arrangements before they commit to a job
whether someone without children haven't
and people without children tend to be
men or younger women and so research
from parents in Performing Arts is an
organization called parents and carers
and Performing Arts sorry found that 9
out of ten mothers and female carers
working in the industry are the primary
carers of children and that same
research found that over 45 percent of
women attend our jobs often because of
care and responsibilities so that's not
a choice that women are actively making
that's a consequence of a lack of
structures to support women with child
care obligations in the music industry
and with that is affordable flexible
high quality child care that just
doesn't exist for our members and where
it does exist it's out of the cost for
most of our members as well so we'll see
that as another barrier to to women
being visible or being able to progress
their careers in the music industry if I
may I would like to uh uh there is a
wonderful Association in in Spain and I
know that they are watching right now
it's called
musica women in the music business and
they did a study last year that tackles
exactly this kind of issues and I think
that the numbers are absolutely
astonishing because only 33 percent of
women in music business against uh 48 33
to 48
we have kids
so 48 of the working force in Spain
female working force has kids and only
33 percent in music business has kids
we have to think why is that it's
something that it's inherently wrong and
it doesn't help us to have kids uh when
the difference is so so so big so I I
think that that's again another huge
barrier John was saying uh when we
decided that we want to work and uh in
this business and that's why also
increasingly we have younger uh women
working in in music it's very good news
that we have younger Generations joining
us but why we decide that it's over for
us when we top uh 40 years old or
something like that then we can't access
in your roles because maybe we decide
that it's now or never we want to have
kids so then we have to say goodbye to
our jobs in order to have a family that
involves also children so I think that's
something that definitely it's a huge
huge issue when we want to have senior
task forces that also involves women
that's um therefore that we can make
decisions
but I mean John you make the point that
the ready availability of flexible
affordable child care is at the root of
this problem and I would disagree and I
would um counter that I mean I I don't
disagree that that is a problem but
that's not just a problem for the music
industry that's a problem for women
right across the country right
um and yet the music industry has a
particular problem retaining its female
Workforce and I would suggest to you
that actually one of the reasons and um
and Marsha as well that having a lack of
women higher up the sort of food chain
in decision-making roles also means an
industry which is not making policies
that are geared towards their female
workforces
um so to you know to what extent uh are
you putting in place measures that could
actually help help that pipeline I mean
we've heard
so much evidence from from those Within
the Music Industry across sectors you
know from classical music right the way
through to pop and everything in between
uh that uh that says you know you kind
of almost have to put up with with
so much negativity and so much bad
treatment and if you if you you know you
don't even bother to report it or
bothered to stand up to it because
that's the end of your career you know
you're done
um you know so what can be done to
overcome that I mean it's going back to
that point about Freelancers and I'm
informal worker networks as well so I've
completely agree with the other
um in some respects that is in policy
and practice in place where we've got
collective bargaining agreements so
we're employed musicians with there's
definitely policy and practice in place
so what you would expect to see from an
employer in terms of maternity leave
what I'm talking about is the freelance
who will rely on the child care sector
to provide that flexible and talk child
care that's the bit that I'm saying is
the barrier to our members so yeah where
we've got collective bargaining
agreements you will see better maternity
and parental leave policies we where the
freelance work for is it's impossible
for us to have those agreements so you
wouldn't see the same and they're
relying on um the child care that exists
outside of employment let's say to be
able to do that
um but again going back to why women
don't raise the head of course it's that
freelance nature again is the minute
someone raises a problem whether that be
sexual harassment lack of facilities for
women discrimination generally what
we'll see at the MU is that they become
the problem so that the person who's
complaining the woman in this instance
is forced out of the workforce or
victimized
um we quite often see in the paper
plated stay in the workforce and move up
the workforce
um yeah it's a massive problem for us
even outside of answer world even within
the industry where people are employees
I mean we still have an issue here I
mean you know a four percent reference
to a four percent reference to
supportive employer yeah I mean that's
not good by any stretch of the
imagination uh you know and it and this
is for
um child care but it's also for
maternity
um issues as well I mean surely this is
this is because
there are a lack a lack of women in
these decision-making capabilities that
are not bringing forward women uh
friendly
policies within the business what can
you do to what can the industry itself
do to address it and what should the
government do to address it I mean we
talk about this a lot about a lot of
women in leadership positions
um and again I think that would be a
game changer in terms of the way the way
the workplace was set up women have got
the lived experience of the things that
they need would be able to inform that
so we're again this key change is an
organization working specifically with
festivals so look at 50 50 gender
balance I think it started off
specifically go festivals but now
keychain is much wider isn't it looking
at organizations you've got
organizations I think she's gave
evidence no idea Khan from women in
control who look at um representation of
women on board and we work with a lot of
these organizations to make sure that
women are in lead to Safe leadership
positions and in decision making
capacities as well
um so those organizations do exist and
we've been according to the industry to
work with them
I would like to comment on this as well
um aif is similar but you know we put a
lot of work into making sure that the
board has a good gender balance
um and end of the road does similar um
our Workforce is about 63 female
um a lot of them occupying roles that
are a lot of the time considered more
male in terms of production staff
Engineers head of technical
um I think it has to start kind of it
has to start somewhere and organizations
like mu like the aif can kind of lead
lead that way
um I think it's it's based on directors
and organizers alone but I think it's
48.48 of aif's kind of members are
females so that's nearly half of the
organizations festivals being female-led
and I think supporting those
organizations to make that change so it
can be seen because that's that's the
important thing isn't it for somebody to
see somebody that looks like them and do
doing a role that they want to be able
to do and just coming back to child care
I want to flag that I think the music
industry has a very specific issue in
that the hours that are expected are
very anti-social they're outside of your
normal nine to fives you're expected to
be up late probably drinking to be
sociable you're expected to work at the
weekends
um and I think
those with child care needs that have to
you know that prioritize family or need
to stay at home because they can't find
good child care they begin to feel
invisible in the industry and they begin
to doubt their Worth or their
contribution
um and then they do also become more
invisible and then you're lacking
representation again and it's a whole
kind of cycle
to what extent do you just think there's
a there's a sense of
I'm going to use the word arrogance it's
probably not the word I'm really
searching for but to what extent is
there just an arrogance at the top of
the industry that kind of says
all this sort of sexual equality all
this sort of you know focusing on uh on
rooting out you know bullying all this
focus on trying to push your quality she
doesn't really apply to us
I think I think there is a lot of
arrogance
around that I think these issues exist
everywhere and even if you're an
organization that feels like you're
doing well you're never going to be
doing well enough there's always more
that you can be doing
um I think with all forms of kind of
prejudice and discrimination a lot of
the time no real change is going to
happen unless people are willing to give
up the power that they have at the top
to make that change possible
I'm just finally before I shut up
um is there anything else that you think
the government
could or should be doing besides the
things you've already mentioned that
would it would move the dial on that I
really think that paternity leave in
this country is is insufficient I think
it's based on a very outdated idea of of
kind of women or childbearers as the
caregivers and supporting partner as the
provider so a lot of I I know from kind
of people that I've worked with they are
the ones who end up taking maternity
leave they are the ones that end up
looking after the children because it's
financially better for them as a couple
to do so and I really think that that is
something that should be addressed yeah
I mean there's a wealth government and
within sectors on that because there's
some sort of there is a kind of stigma
about guys who take paternity leave as
well
thank you just two to other issues that
are raised quite frequently from our
female members is um the way maternity
allowance applies to the self-employed
and the keeping in touch days it is only
10 days
um which a lot of our female members say
that's not enough to sustain the careers
while they're on maternity leave um it's
different to being employed isn't it the
the freelance musicians need to stay on
fixes and because Radars and that means
working regularly for them if not
they'll just drop off and we perpetuate
the problem and so that's one another
issue that's being raised the issue of
share parental leave for Freelancers as
well so self-employed parents aren't
eligible for share parental pay so that
current system of maternity allowance
places the entire Bid And if Child Care
on the woman
um and office no financial support to to
the partner who might like to share some
of the child care and as I've just
explained that flexibility of child care
for a Freelancers position is crucial
lifted to keep the business afloat while
they're on maternity leave so there's
definitely two two points that I would
add to that Martin
did you have to add to that
oh well that's a recent mother myself
I I feel
that I'm definitely very lucky because
my situation is not at all what I can
see around me I'm not a freelancer and
as John was saying that's huge because
of course then I can count off on the
the the the support system uh behind me
um and also I think that somehow when
motherhood hits when you are already on
a senior position it's way better it's
way easier but if you just want to start
a career then you're gonna commit you're
gonna say no to so many things
um the same study that I was mentioning
uh before
um from mujeres
81 of women working in music in Spain 81
percent
um
said that they were gonna give up on
something
uh had a children having a personal life
or getting a raise because they had to
take care of I don't know a sick parent
or something like that
um and that's that's huge the way that
uh our social and family
um environment affects us only as women
it's uh it's tremendous it doesn't have
anything to do with uh with men and I
can see that in my in my in my
environment I consider myself a very
very lucky but that's definitely not
um the the usual thing
Lauren um I think you made a really
really pertinent point about anti-social
hours late at night
irregular as well we all know with child
care providers they want to have a kind
of a consistent customer nine to five
five days a week uh
other festivals themselves doing
anything to make sure that female
artists
technicians
can bring children to festivals and find
child care
um I can't speak to the wider climate
um because I don't have that knowledge
but I can speak to end of the road and
yes we do
we provide
um
extra passes for carers do come with
parents sometimes we provide extra
accommodations so extra Caravans extra
Boutique tents
to make sure that if you are working
over the festival and you have child
care responsibilities that they can kind
of be tied in together you don't
necessarily have to leave
your child kind of at home or with the
carer or with grandparents which is
often the way that a lot of people I
know kind of get by so so yes those
those options are there for for parents
in End of the Road thank you for that
very helpful and
do you perceive that there is a
difference
between festivals and I'm going to use
the term led by women
do they make more accommodations
um
kind of there has to be I think as as
with anything that's led by a lived
experience like I'm not a mother but I'm
a woman and I think that perspective
comes into play and I think that's why
it's really important to have that
representation at the top level
to have somebody that really knows what
it's like to go through those things or
at least have those people in senior
positions within your organization even
if they're not at the top
and do you think it also makes a
difference when looking at issues around
safety of female Festival goers the
efforts that go into making sure that
there are sufficient safe spaces that
there are properly trained security is
did are you aware of a difference that
when there are women at the top of
organizations they make more of an
effort to make sure that happens
aware of a difference
I don't know I again I can only speak to
yeah
um yes because we've I don't know
anybody in this industry that hasn't
been through some form of sexual
harassment or abuse or discrimination
based on their gender or sexuality or
ethnic background
um
so yes I think we all if we've been
through that then we we care more
thank you Elliot thank you very much
Sharon thank you very much panel
um John I'd like to come to you if I may
on the issue of non-disclosure
agreements
um and ndas this has been something
that's been flagged up throughout the
course of of this inquiry
um we've had evidence both from Dr
Cassandra Jones but also from the chief
executive of ism citing the use of
non-disclosure agreements and ndas is a
as a reason
um and as a factor for bullying and
harassment in in the industry and the
inability to report now this is where I
think
um the committee is very keen to get a
better idea because of course NDA is
aren't supposed to be used for
um covering up crimes essentially I mean
let's just call a spade a spade
um in your experience in the industry
how commonplace is the use of ndas
um specifically
um on the issue of abuse and things that
should be classified as criminal but
also more widely in terms of poor
behavior and things that might not
necessarily pass the the sniff test if
we call it that
um how commonplace have you found it and
and how and why in your experience are
they used
obviously difficult to say how
commonplace it is because a lot of ndas
will stop members talking to us about it
but I do know from working with members
that um ndas are used for exactly the
way you've described
um quite often used to hide the
discriminancy behavior on lawful
Behavior or sexual harassment or assault
and quite often used to allow
perpetrators to stay in the workplace or
move from where a place to workplace
with impunity and the person who's
experience sexual harassment or the
discriminative behavior is often can't
work with that person again for obvious
reasons so they're the ones who are
suffering this
um again I couldn't speak to how
widespread the news because of the issue
of ndas I can tell you what we would
like to see is is in the use of ndas is
similar actions to those that have
recently been taken in higher education
and I think it's really recent that's
happened in February with being
prohibited for the use of covering up
sexual harassment or discrimination we'd
love to see similar mechanism in place
for the music industry well or more
widely to stop the misuse sorry of ndas
as
stand so I'm I was going to ask you what
the government should do so you've
answered that question thank you but the
um
um so but as things stand if what if one
of your female members came to you
um what would your advice be to them
um at the moment or would you or are you
tied by the State of the State of play
at the moment unless there's legislative
change we'd need legislative change and
it depends again it would be um in some
cases if the NBA was there to protect
our member to protect our members
identity then 100 if that's what our
member wanted so again we'd be led by
the actions of Our member but yeah we
would need legislation we need help with
this
and thank you for that and that was um
very succinct so thank you chair thank
you very much can I just thank all of
our Witnesses for the evidence that
you've given this afternoon it's been
hugely appreciated Lauren I think we
through quite a few things that we'd
love you to follow up uh in writing uh
if either of the other two witnesses
feel that there is anything that you
would like to add in writing after the
session please do so but thank you very
much for the information that you've
given us today order order order
thank you
the proceeding has ended